[Music]
Comcast isn't freezing to death in this
logo this guy decides to retrieve this
box using this janky-ass ladder just as
the store opens on what I assume is
Black Friday
where was this cartoonishly butch
security when the store opened and that
mucho mark greeter was trampled people
fighting over Christmas decorations on
Black Friday instead of Bobbitt Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers Furby or other
toys that will prove how old I am
suddenly everyone is calm and orderly in
the checkout line maybe they saw those
other people get tasered for no reason
and realize the security guards at
neutral Mart mean business by them is a
kid nativity play happening in this
store at the local elementary school
burned down or did the director convince
them to have it here because it made the
transition easier this guy clearly has a
mild case of super strength if he's able
to carry that television under one arm
and that concludes our delightfully
out-of-context slow-mo nightmare holiday
montage even though grandma knows the
Krampus rules she is still presumably
suspicious every Christmas despite no
one summoning him even till the first
graders at says it was just a cheap
marketing ploy and then didn't sell
Pepsi coke kid who cannot discern the
difference between Coke and Pepsi even
though Coke is delicious and Pepsi as
garbage was drop kicking em into the
manger really the best way there was no
way that kid drop kicked that other kid
into any kind of manger unless his
parents allowed the fighting to go on
will pass the major part and we missed
that after why you pole you can do that
alone how about you just started a fight
in the middle of a play you can't do
that at all go to your room Jesus this
couple is completely forgotten not a
parent offend me I started with this
Star Wars does this family speak in
perfect German to English translation do
they have a Babel Fish in their ears
last year I found in my bed mom human -
the last time that was their dog mom
somehow believes that her sister's
English Bulldog takes human side mom is
just now noticing that Santa is looking
at her daughter's ass instead of when
she put the picture in the frame or when
she got the picture the first time or
when she was shown proof she had plenty
of opportunities before now to look at
her own family photo is what I'm saying
how our Hummer shakes the whole house
because he's obnoxious just want to make
sure you understand that this guy isn't
Randy Quaid in the scene they're just a
little cranky cuz the Steelers lost tell
your Aunt Sarah about your Presidential
Fitness Award he uses the previous five
seconds of dialogue to beat me over the
head with how butch Linda and Howard's
daughters are Oh would you ask Santa for
this air
toys are video games so analysis either
Beth thinks that Howie juniors mental
challenges are the result of failing
kidneys or she doesn't know what
dialysis is gross fat kid drinking soda
straight from a two-liter bottle and
then immediately burping cliche as I was
in training Leslie what were you
training for uh said Eagle Scouts for
some reason Howard and company are
acting like being an Eagle Scout is
something to laugh about
but becoming an Eagle Scout is pretty
hard right I wouldn't know because I'm a
lazy asshole but I assume it would
require a lot of discipline and hard
work and a gun-toting survivalist type
like Howard would find it respectable
what are you now a Jew that's actually
racist so to survive you had to
slaughter and eat his reindeer including
Rudolph eight tiny reindeer
get it yeah but if you also ate Rudolph
that makes nine so your pun based falls
apart this kid hates Christmas spoiler
talk as much as Marty McFly hates being
called a chicken in the Back to the
Future sequels
it's a very curious button that sets him
off Max's letter starts to get awkward
for the grown-ups yet no one gets up to
stop Stevie from continuing to read
given the max has retained all of his
family members during his life I have
trouble seeing how this Christmas can be
any different from Max's ten previous
Christmases also did someone
cryogenically freeze the kid from
Jumanji and thaw amount last year to be
in this movie
this dartboard in the background is just
asking for darts to be thrown into the
wall around it this is also an orgy of
evidence this is a boy's room stack of
board games minecraft pictures toy plane
numerous off-screen things I can't even
see but I know were there I mean how do
you even sleep in this room even the
assholes you normally can't stand seeing
asshole to a ten-year-old kid I guess
Krampus is able to interpret a ripped up
letter to Santa as Max wishing his
entire family was gone
Kevin McCallister actually said out loud
he wished his family would disappear and
the worst thing that happened him was
Joe Pesci showed up
Krampus rides in on the same clown that
the rhinoceros from James and the Giant
Peach used to eat James's parents
blackout waits to shut down this one
houses power lasts because that's how
electricity works when you accidentally
summoned a Christmas demon we find out
later that the snowmen that appear
represent people Krampus is too
into the underworld or whatever the
snowman must indicate his first victim
was Abraham Lincoln the Turner's are in
Hawaii the Lambert's are in Florida the
Cartwright stopped talking to us after
masses little incident how convenient
for the impending evil Christmas demon
all the neighbors are out of town except
for the ones they don't talk to causing
them to be completely isolated I can't
talk like a normal person and say ups
because this is a half assed DHL product
placement and look how much better we
are than them while they successfully
brought packages to your door they did
not personally greet you so stick it you
pee your ass ups then can I walk over
and check on him I could see if anyone
else has power on the way she'll be fine
based on Beth's conversation with a
boyfriend from earlier their parents
wouldn't allow her to leave the house
when there was no blizzard now in an
extremely large blizzard has taken out
all power the phone lines and cell phone
communication she'll be fine
I know teenage horniness is a powerful
thing but I can't imagine it being
powerful enough to inspire a teenage
girl to go out into a blizzard with wind
chills powerful enough to give you
frostbite
apparently Krampus went to the same
fright school as that naked dude from it
follows did that's what you get for
being deliver a cyst also Krampus
doesn't ever actually kill anyone he
just takes them to help so my question
is why did this guy get to stay in this
van when all the other Krampus victims
that we soon see get carted off to the
underworld feeling like you're safe
again when you actually aren't cliche
[Music]
was that she can't don't crawl this
jack-in-the-box thing he's in a box but
how what happened Daniel pg-13 or he's
getting away hey she's fine she's it
turns a few problems it's been over an
hour and Beth's parents are collectively
less concerned and they should be
Donna's clearly more trusting of Derek
than he should be and they let their
daughter go blizzard do you think your
Hummer could get through this mess this
asshole Howard has been complaining the
whole movie that Tom and Sarah are rich
and her assholes because of it but he
owns a Hummer let him out of
your sight for one second Oh shotgun
wedding shotgun wedding I thought she
was gonna say freeze to death in a
blizzard the glass is punched in then I
guess Krampus broke through the
windshield and disintegrated him because
the glass wouldn't be that tucked in if
Krampus pulled him out through the
windshield Mary used to fight over who
got to play sir remember when movies
built expositional dialogue into
dialogue that simultaneously moved the
plot forward instead of just lazily
throwing in some lines about the past I
don't I read somewhere that over 350
million Rubik's cubes have been sold
over the years and I think 175 million
of them were sold to be movie props
probably just squirrels in this weather
well if they're hearing sounds directly
above them then the squirrels probably
just found their way inside to keep warm
you know since there is a second floor
and an attic between them and the roof
right now
making it impossible to actually hear
anything happening on the roof at that
volume see squirrels Sara says this
instead of what the actual was that had
to be playing with their nuts
oh he decides that she's going to
sacrifice her own face to see what's
going on inside the chimney
I guess because Derek's family didn't
have a German grandma they got abducted
by Krampus in record time too bad we
aren't following Derek's family or we
could be done by now mostly a gas line
blew
you know the gas lines that run up the
middle of the chimney and also blow
directionally that's one of them even
though Howard's legs were bitten by a
monster and he was pulled under the snow
apparently all he got out of that were
some minor injuries wait so Tom here's
his daughter screaming bloody murder and
instead of staying out here until he
finds her he hobbles back to his house
with his brother-in-law that he hates so
that he can bandage his flesh wound
Linda pulls out her seasonal swearing
this time of year and they teach you how
to make peppermint schnapps I know
they're just trying to show that she's
unfit to be around children but there's
no way she's going to actually show them
how to make peppermint schnapps without
a working stove to melt some sugar and
peppermint to mix with a bottle of vodka
all right but don't you rat me out
underage drinking she wasn't it Derek's
but that doesn't mean anything yes it
does it means she's probably dead damn
near frostbite in under 4 minutes this
is more evidence for the Thomases parent
for letting Beth leave column back when
Howard handed Tom this gun he didn't
give him any more ammo and when Howard
got attacked by the Gopher from
Caddyshack Tom fired up two rounds so
where the hell did these extra rounds
come from you got best bet is to stay
put
board up all the doors and windows let
my daughter freeze to death but if she
somehow can make it back to the house
she'll have no way of getting in it's
the perfect plan okay Jesus just I
almost forgot there's an unsupervised
baby in the house one that stayed
relatively quiet during this whole
exchange that's never a good sign if
you've already had a rough slightly
disturbing Christmas Eve the last thing
you need to watch are those creepy
rankin/bass claymation Christmas movies
Tom has such a large quantity of scrap
wood lying around his house he could
cover up all the doors and windows with
it I don't think Tom has actually looked
through those binoculars yet or he would
clearly be able to see you that he can't
see through the drapes as more of these
snowmen appear I'm starting to suspect
that Krampus is actually just Calvin
from Calvin and Hobbes
she always gets all weird on Christmas I
can buy her not telling her son what
actually happened to her family but I
find it hard to believe she didn't make
up a more feasible story that would
still take place around Christmastime
explaining her weird behavior grandma
who told these assholes to keep the fire
going trusted everyone in this horrible
family to do that Krampus his plan for
child abduction relies on them not being
in their bedrooms but being light
sleepers and downstairs within view of
the fireplace
Ruby steals its gingerbread man from
Trek no one else in the living room
wakes up during this madness the
Christmas tradition of putting a dead
highly flammable pine tree in your
living room that tiny-ass fire
extinguisher is going to put out that
large fire since I'm a strict grandma
waited for to death to finally say
something about the wonderful world of
Krampus Tom what you think are these
parents not going to go outside and see
what happened to their kid just comes
for us all grandma plays the pronoun
game in German which is somehow less fun
than the English pronoun game please
listen o me suddenly knows English well
enough to walk us through her backstory
this Christmas was darker less cheerful
and snowflakes came down as if the whole
world was a microscope only outsource
for flashbacks to Tim Burton
it was Krampus roll credits that Krampus
didn't take me sit night so this is the
story of grandma UMI's parents getting
pulled into the underworld because she
wished for it to happen my question now
is why is Krampus currently killing DHL
guys and other randoms on the street if
the reason he's here is because of max
complaining about his family evil Santa
jesus H Almighty uh you did see your kid
get dragged up a chimney right I'm
hitting Howie back a little late for
that right
you waited through the whole story to
think about going out to get your son
Christmas jealous
towles oh he goes back to exclusively
German and no one is pissed off about
that even though she proved that she can
speak English moments earlier
how does I'm old enough to know when a
life is coming at you with his pants
down I feel like having its pants down
would give you the upper hand or at
least the upper pants even after all
this insane has gone down only now is
Linda becoming suspicious of the
unmarked presence that showed up less
than 24 hours ago you just want to get
these rewrapped for the kids these
presents survived the fire enough to
just require some rewrapping
damnit I must have slept through the
rest of the movie and gremlins started
playing wait it didn't
that's just what is happening in the
movie someone owes Spielberg an
explanation Beth you up there where have
you been
I know these girls don't see their
cousin often and they aren't super
bright but any kid knows not to follow a
creepy voice that's clearly not your
cousin into the Attic I think all this
might be my fault no subtitles so I can
only assume she said yes it's definitely
your fault thanks for killing all of us
Howard decides to leave max Oh me
Dorothy and a baby in the living room
defenseless while he goes and
investigates other noises because the
movie decided we need to congruent
action sequences pointing a loaded gun
with your finger on the trigger around a
room that might contain you're
frightened hiding nieces this thing is
definitely terrifying but what are all
these teeth for if it swallows kids hole
I'm sure this is just a funny joke and I
laughed at it like a moron but this
asshole bothers to wipe his chin after a
meal movie ignores two fundamental facts
about nail guns they require compressed
air and the nose must be pushed in for
it to fire convenient giant wood cutting
board is convenient excessive licking
also demon baby Frenchie
even though this robot is stabbing Tom
multiple times in the back Tom will
continue on like he didn't get stabbed
multiple times in the back
[Music]
penis ex machina also Howard's dog is
able to approach and eat the last
gingerbread man hardly making a sound
this doll size creature is able to hang
a full sized human woman with the power
of flight and Christmas lights that bear
is an extremely ineffective minion that
jack-in-the-box can eat a whole person
the owl doll can get created with
Christmas lights and all the damn bear
can do is barely fight Linda's arm
instead of sneaking up on der clown with
the axe Linda decides to let it know
she's coming up behind it giving it time
to get away kit assumes after hours of
ass-kicking from Krampus that this dog
who is now dead by the way will make a
difference
evil third clown jack-in-the-box makes
in a school sound cat and Rosie will be
waste time on an invisible fight between
der clown and der dog der clown
inexplicably waits to do anything to
these people while they all try to
remove the Allen doll movie suddenly got
a troll to vibe that I'm sure is an
accident when everyone is sorry that we
need to make a break for it
well don't run too fast you might get a
crevasse not only does Krampus have evil
powers that cause power to sort of come
back but he also has ironic powers
because up on the housetop starts
playing can't you just go through the
big gaping hole that the elves made when
they crashed through the front window
the window oh sure now you think about
it but now your kid is gonna stop you
from going in there because you're too
slow to think of it
Krampus continues coming down the
chimney even though he certainly knows
all the people he wants to kill just
left well I guess grandma did her duty
as a distraction but I still can't
figure out why this asshole even
bothered with her movie realizes it
didn't kill off characters fast enough
during the duration of the movie so it
spends the last 10 minutes killing
everyone else without them putting up a
fight winter tremors Tom shoots that
gopher demon with his new shotgun that
suddenly has infinite shotgun shells the
snowplow isn't covered in feet of snow
and I knew you could just make
characters you wanted to kill off just
vanish into the ground I could have made
a successful career writing horror
movies you don't have to be creative
yeah yeah it's a car won't start cliche
but I'm wondering how this kid manages
to reach the gas pedals this kid is also
fluent in German and he's an asshole
I don't know where he finds all the time
to know this you don't even know how to
drive a car you're 10
wait does the ripoff of trimmers kill
Krampus his henchmen do littering why
are any of them still there they did
what they came to do maybe the
screenwriter convince him to stay
because max wanted to renege on his deal
that's racist at first I thought Krampus
was a principal demon punishing kids who
were bad and forgot what it meant to
have Christmas spirit
yeah his methods are a little extreme
but he had a purpose now that max has
clearly learned his lesson and Krampus
just throws him into hell anyway I'm
starting to think he's no better than an
internet troll
you know who you are it was all a dream
or was it cliche they all seemed pretty
pumped but if my version of Helen was
getting to spend a nice Christmas
morning with my family inside of a snow
globe I'd probably take it got a hand it
to this movie for an ending that makes
you think it was all a dream then pulls
back and makes you realize it's not only
real but it's got a pretty poetic kind
of ending they're all just in that snow
globe forever and ever I like that
ending it's not happy it's got to say
though this is a lot of missing people
happening around Christmas that no one
ever asked
questions about feels like Krampus would
be more of a known evil entity if he's
got so many families trapped in snow
globes all the creatures show up for one
last lunch at the camera for some reason
I guess they see the unseen audience but
two Krampus this has to be pretty
unusual behavior to see his minions just
lunge towards something for no reason
buzz what could Andy possibly get that
is worse than you
as for Nicodemus they must move your
house to the Lee of the stone that's why
you always leave a note
but now you know there was a man named
Jack Dawson and that he saved me I don't
even have a picture of him he exists now
only in my memory
[Music]
Oh baby